what's up reject nation john here we are
about to show you our trailer reaction
for james wan's newest horror movie
malignant
very excited about this didn't even know
this trailer was dropping today
if you could remember to subscribe hit
that notification bell our original
intro got a little messed up we've
actually had a lot of trailers to shoot
today and keep an
eye out this afternoon because i i can
already feel the comments coming in
where's your jackass forever reaction
it's coming later today keep your eyes
peeled for jackass forever but for right
now
enjoy malignant it's a fun one
uh
oh what a horrible horrible way to have
premonitions
our family hurt you in a way that i
can't even imagine
[Music]
no he is not
devil made me do it
oh
he's got like a j horror vibe to this a
little bit
he wants to talk
[Music]
[Music]
dude
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
he's the devil
[Applause]
god i love james wants horror movies
right damn
he yes he just knows how to just get you
excited for a horror film
there are a lot of people who make cool
horror nowadays but james juan is is
like in the upper echelon of like when i
see that trailer i'm like i can tell
what your style is doing i can see how
much punch even
just from a few clips that this is gonna
happen while there's like not
all of it looks entirely original in its
execution there's some stuff that feels
a little bit familiar
in the trope terrain but i think what
james wong consistently brings even in
stuff that could feel a little bit you
know tropey or
reminiscent of things that i've already
seen done a bunch of times is he
constantly brings like a distinct visual
palette
to whatever he's doing doesn't just look
like another insidious or conjuring
movie and while you do get the flares of
that he's
it really does feel like he's bringing a
bit of that j horror inspiration
specifically into this one like whoever
this gabriel character
is a lot of the effects around that i
was actually getting my mind was sort of
flashing to the eye
yeah yeah i get what you mean it has
this sort of yeah aesthetic where you
know
it doesn't seem like it's set in japan
but like you know it has
that domestic sort of it feels like
you're going to watch this character
deteriorate more and more and experience
some kind of paranormal situation that's
very much
personally tied to them yeah female
horror century character who is very
much tied to the demonic
entity a lot of this did seem j
horror-esque and especially in its
execution but i think his experience
with films like aquaman have also helped
him get better at knowing how to handle
even crazier visual effects like this
trailer had a little bit more cgi than
i'm used to
for a james bond horror film does all of
it look great no not really
but there's a lot of it that does feel
very unsettling and i think that's the
thing i love about his films is that
they're like spooky fun and even if
they're not like
always terrifying like to me insidious
was the scariest one he's ever
like in cities it's the scariest one
he's done conjuring is the best
film i think he's done this just looks
like a really good
entertaining time that still is going
out of its way to feel more personal
than your average horror movie you know
yeah i feel like james one is really
good at
that if anything is making blockbuster
scale horror that you know has a lot of
effects and has a lot of those moving
parts but that doesn't forget about
the like part of what makes the
conjuring work so well is that it is a
personal tale
of this family and you're really getting
to see what the effects of the
paranormal experience are
on them and so yeah i have a lot of
faith in him generally
and i mean this looks like a cool kind
of mixture of
what i'm familiar with from him and then
some new stuff as well and also you know
it's like the more
horror this guy does not that he said he
wants to only do horror but you get to
see yeah how his
approach grows and changes and i mean
you can just see so much
it's like some trailers just play like
oh yeah you know like that's a neat
pitch but i could just
like pick little filmmaking cues up even
from this
yeah it's interesting because this the
big star of what this trailer is
the lead actress looks like she's doing
a great job but i feel like the real
star of this trailer is james wand
yeah that's the thing he's he's one of
those few directors who has that quality
right now
yeah who was just like what's he going
to come back with what's the style again
because he hasn't done horror in a while
and there was this point where it seemed
like he really wanted to take a break
from it so that's what gets me excited
about it because it does feel like
there's a little
there's something here that feels
reinvigorating you know um
who's the guy who david sandberg there's
like david sandberg and then lee wannell
who have worked with james wan as he's
produced uh certain films
and then as they've become bigger
directors and you could feel that
there's some inspiration they've had
from james wants films and now it seems
like it's coming full circle i'm sort of
feeling an inspiration
of things he's picked up on from david f
sandberg because i'm getting some lights
out vibes here
and then also lee juanel in terms of a
lot of the way he works with the camera
work
uh so yeah yeah that's what i mean is it
seems like this little
circle of all them and then whoever
conjuring three i don't know maybe that
guy
but in terms of that specific unit of
those three that that i mentioned
it does feel like a hodgepodge of all
that there's something here that feels
like back to basics but also
refreshing yeah weird it's like back to
basics but with
the all the resources and i'm like
yeah it's like there's those moments
where it's like you get these vast
expanses of fog and beautiful lighting
instead of you know insidious you're
much more contained
so you had to see his ear marks but on a
much grander scale
i'm very fascinated to see how all
that's going to work out and what this
ultimately wind up being because it does
look with some of those cg sequences
like it is going to get pretty
fantastical yeah then other elements the
emotional elements especially look very
grounded yeah i mean he's another guy
who too gets you excited for like the
filmmaking aspect and not just
like is it gonna be scary what i will
say is that i think
that trailer is probably faster pace
than the actual movie will be i feel
like it'll be
a lot more dread focused
in its tone that's just the impression
i'm getting this sort of feels like they
were cutting together a snappy trailer
pulling from like some of the most
exciting built up moments
yeah but i think it'll probably be a lot
more slower paced
uh in its actual execution but yeah guys
what did you think about this trailer
are you excited for it leave your
thoughts down below literally
no knew nothing about it before watching
it other than james wan directed this
movie subscribe click that bell thank
you to perfect world for sponsoring this
video
last but not least
maria hammond maria this this is a
situation
that i would call you during because you
are such a caring
comforting person you're always looking
out for people so if i was in some kind
of haunted scenario where i'm having
visions and i need comfort and i need
guidance who am i going to come to
i will come to you out of anybody at our
patreon because
you could vanquish the evil spirits with
your light
with your everlasting benevolence maria
me more people in this world like you
and i hope that
soon you know like uh maybe a next james
juan movie
will star somebody just like you you can
star in it and then you know you can
bring that
masked uh love to the world maria
anyway i hope that your life isn't
paranormal in any
scary kind of way
and that you know you're having a good
summer i love you maria